I'm going to give you the season
prediction which is the big one and so
you don't know that for the last four
years NFL seasons I have been very
pessimistic and have predicted the Jets
not to make the playoffs 5 and 11 6 and
10 I've been very down it's the one
place where I'm not a true optimist
however I have newfound light for this
season I am very excited I'm a big
believer in the coach bowls that's
Patrick demeanor and I think chris ivory
is one of the grossly underestimated
running backs in the NFL and so I think
that the New York Jets are gonna go ten
and six and here's why because i think
the buffalo bills are the most grossly
overrated team in the NFL everybody's
buying into the hyperbole I am
completely blown away by people's belief
that they're going to the playoffs and
they're gonna win nine or ten games it's
a five and 11 teen they stink and we're
gonna find those openings of victory we
lose some games along the way I know
that most people have the Jets at five
and 11 6 and 10 I know the most
optimistic have us at nine and seven I'm
going all in on this team I feel it I
feel it in a big way ten and six I
recognize that I put myself out there
but i believe baby i believe the
prediction is heartache feel I feel like
Jets are gonna end up really strong but
I'm very worried about the Steelers and
the Chiefs running the table and when
you wouldn't Doug double-digit games and
you don't make the playoffs that's
heartache I don't know if you guys know
that but that's heartache to me that's
the ultimate heartache
you